to confirm a story for me sure Charles
at the All-Star game he says it's an
All-Star game all the guys get together
in the room beforehand Justice before
they announced it to the crowd so Kareem
is sitting in a corner he says you were
in the locker room reading a paper I'm
with like bird Mikhail and Carl Malone
and I said you know I never met Karine
before
they're like go up and say hello to him
and he's sitting over in the corner by
himself with his head down this is the
first time I've seen you and he said Mr
Abdul-Jabbar Mr Jabar can I talk to you
he looks up I'm reading I told him I was
reading yes
I turn around
so that's a true story there was times
that I just couldn't be bothered right
trust me now now Charles is making me
pay for that yeah
I didn't know what to say I was like
okay